show that countries that have two or
more official languages have lower
incidents of dementia of Alzheimer's at
the national level uh with actually a
direct correlation between the number of
languages spoken in the country and um
the incidents of dementia so the more
languages are spoken officially in the
country the um lower the incidents of
dementia so hello and welcome to the
Shiki science show where in this video I
spoke with Fiora kamaran professor of
psychology at Northwestern University
and is the principal investigator of the
Northwestern bilingualism and
psycholinguistics research laboratory
most recently Professor Marian published
her excellent book The Power of language
which I read earlier this year that
discusses how languages change the way
we perceive the world as well as the
benefits of bilingualism here we discuss
many of these topics and more I hope you
enjoy so hi Fior thank you so much for
joining me today and welcome to the
Shiki science
you thank you for having me it's a
pleasure to be here thank you so I
wanted to reach out to you because
earlier this year I read your book The
Power of language and I thought it was
amazing and then I just knew I had to
have a conversation with you about it
but I think initially so much that that
uh that means a lot to me thank you and
so I think initially the reason I picked
it up as a book to read was for many
reasons one is that it mentioned
discussing about the connection with
language and memory and the way we uh
perceived the world around around us
also because um it talks about the
benefits of bilingualism and at the time
and still currently I'm trying to learn
Japanese so I read it for that reason um
as a bit of motivation and then lastly
as a biologist I'm fascinated by the
question of how like cells communicate
how our tissues communicate with each
other and I thought maybe I'll gleam
some insight from reading this book so I
think that somewhat leads on to like my
first question which is what actually
are the key components that make up a
language that's a a seemingly easy
question but it um it really isn't so
most of the time when we think about
language we think of the natural
languages that people speak like you and
I now are speaking in English so we
think of English or you mention Japanese
um and incidentally the Japanese edition
of the book is coming out next week so
I'm very excited about that it it's a
beautiful cover but yes so most of the
time people think about natural human
languages and sort of stop at that
um but what is a language very much
depends on the definition we use how we
Define
language uh the way I think about
language or one way to think about
language is a is as a symbolic system
that allows us to use symbols to encode
information transmit it over space and
time and then decod it at the other end
and if we use that definition of a
language as a symbolic system um um then
natural languages that people speak are
not the only ways uh to to not the only
types of languages out there we also
have artificial languages um usually
people think about that as computer
languages but there are other artificial
languages as well um that are being
created in books and movies uh for
research as well uh some consider math a
language because math uses uh numbers as
symbols to communicate to encode
information
um some consider music a language again
because you use symbols to
transmit uh information like sound over
space and time so the definition of
language that I use in the book is much
broader I see and so what got you
interested in languages um in the first
place like what is it that fascinates um
about
it um well to start with I grew up with
more than one language so I grew up in
Eastern Europe with uh Romanian as my
native language and Russian being the
official language of the country I lived
in at the time which is uh which was one
of the former Soviet republics and then
I studied uh English in school and then
uh French in college and um
then Spanish uh around myself and then I
married into a Dutch family so I was uh
being exposed and learning multiple
languages and I was noticing that when I
was using these different languages um
they changed the way I interacted with
the world in um interesting
ways and when I try to read more about
this I noticed that there isn't really
much about multilingualism bilingualism
people who speak multiple languages most
of the research on language was from the
perspective of monolingualism people who
only speak one language language um I
was as a teenager very interested in
philosophy so at some point I thought I
might go the philosophy route but um
instead I went the cognitive psychology
route and uh cognitive science route and
became interested in the relationship
between language and mind and how um
language and and mind are interconnected
how one influences the other uh
specifically from the point of view of
people speak multiple languages really
using bilingualism and multilingualism
as a way to get insight and get
information you cannot get about
language in mind when you only look at
one language and speakers of one
language only so um I started doing
research on bilingualism and
multilingualism uh eventually starting a
bilingualism and multilingualism lab um
my first restudy on bilingualism and
multilingualism was actually as an
undergraduate nearly 30 years ago now my
first presentation was about uh gestures
in bilingual speakers and how people who
speak multiple languages use different
gestures and different non-verbal
communication when they switch
languages um so after many years of
doing Empirical research on bilingualism
and Publishing it in in research
journals peerreview journals I wanted to
bring this work to a broader audience
outside the laboratory outside Academia
where uh only a small number of people
uh reads it and try to make it
accessible and bring accurate
information uh to a general audience
people who speak toal languages but
really um Society at large because I do
think that it tells us a lot about um
the human capacity for language about
learning about thinking about human
potential in general so um that's a long
answer to your question but I hope I
hope it gives some insight into where
I'm coming from yeah for sure and so I
think um one of the facts that surprised
me when I read your book initially was
the fact that there are more bilingual
multilingual people in the world than
monolinguals like I guess myself um well
I'm trying to become bilingual um so
that initially shocked me and then uh
what you then go on to talk about is all
the the benefits that are associated
with knowing more than one language and
so would you be able to discuss what
some of these findings
show yes sure um I will pull back a
little bit by saying that even though
you think of yourself as a monolingual I
guess if we use that broader definition
of language uh where it's not just
natural languages and you uh also use
math and you also uh maybe use Music
you're not as monolingual as you think
because each of those yeah each of those
symbolic systems change the way you
think um and you can you know think
about how math Chang changes the way
uh people can construct knowledge make
discoveries um Advance
scientifically um literacy when you
learn to read your your brain your mind
is uh Chang in the same way learning
another language changes uh how our
brain and our mind work so it's not
surprising that with the acquisition of
a new symbolic systems you're going to
see some
consequences um and these consequences
are present throughout the lifetime from
the very earliest age from babies and
infants uh through young adulthood and
then through old age so um there are so
many changes just because uh the the
effects are pervasive that it would take
you know hours to talk about all of them
so I'll just select a few throughout the
lifespan uh lifespan I'll start with
babies um to say that when when uh when
we B we are born we can hear uh the
sounds of all of the world's
languages we are uh metaphorically
speaking citizens of the world but then
throughout the first months and years of
life our uh system our language systems
become tuned to our to the sounds of our
native language and the languages that
we are exposed to and um eventually we
are no longer sometimes even able to
hear the distinctions that exist in
other languages and don't exist in our
native languages so languages vary in
the number of vowels they have number of
consonants they have um and the most
famous uh examples of that I think in
Western nations are perhaps how speakers
of Spanish sometimes have difficulties
with a b and V sound or speakers of
Japanese sometimes have difficulties
with the r and l sounds of course um
English speakers also have difficulties
with a lot of sounds of other languages
like some of the Scandinavian vowels for
example um what's interesting is that
when you are a bilingual or multilingual
baby you keep that window uh that
perceptual window open for a longer
period of time um so that's one of the
uh consequences of being exposed to
multiple languages from uh an early age
then um so this is an infancy then in
childhood there is some evidence that
children who grow up with two or more
languages um develop metalinguistic and
metacognitive abilities uh a bit earlier
than children who grow up with one
language only and what metalinguistic
ability refers to is the ability to
reason about
language um and I'll give you an example
when you are a bilingual or multilingual
child you know that the the same object
can have uh multiple names so for
example I can call this a pan or I can
call it this sto or I can call this RKA
and uh it doesn't change the entity the
item itself so from an earlier age
bilingual children multilingual children
understand that the object and its name
are not one and the same that they are
separate and you can use different names
to refer um to the same uh object so
this is uh this ability to reason about
language uh of course monolinguals
eventually develop it as well but they
tend to develop it uh a bit later so
that's one of the
consequences uh in childhood then when
we move through
adulthood one of the most studied
consequences of bilingualism and
multilingualism is
the executive
function uh component of cognition so
executive function is really a set of
skills it encompasses multiple uh
abilities Co in cognitive control
inhibition
facilitation um and it seems that people
who speak two or more
languages show some um on some of the
components of executive function they
outperform monolingual uh speakers
especially
uh people who are older at at the
different of the developmental ends of
the Continuum earlier in childhood and
later in uh adulthood and the argument
there is that because bilinguals and
multilinguals constantly used two or
more languages um they have a lot of
experience facilitating the language
they are using and inhibiting the other
languages that are not being used at
that point in time so right now we're
speaking in English we have to focus on
facilitate and privilege English and um
not use any of the Japanese you might
you may know any of the French or
Spanish or Dutch or whatever other
languages I may know and really stay
with English and this constant
experience with language with um um
controlling our languages translates to
a changes to Executive function Beyond
language in other domains of uh
cognition I should say that the
literature on Executive function
in bilinguals is uh not very clearcut
it's controversial uh these findings
have been challenged so not every
experiment uh finds um that bilinguals
outperform
monolinguals and sometimes people get up
in arms about it but I don't think we
should be really throwing the baby out
with the bath ERS they say because the
right way to ask the question is what
aspects of executive function are
changed by what aspects of bilingualism
multilingualism and under what
circumstances and what I mean by that is
bilingual experience is not this
monolithic thing there are multiple uh
kinds of bilinguals or multilinguals
they differ in how they learn their
languages the ages in which they learn
at which they learn their languages how
fluent they are um Which languages
dominant what settings they use their
languages how recently they've used
their languages how similar the
languages are how many languages they
have this is just a tiny fraction of
variables on which bilinguals and
multilinguals differ so um clearly if we
we we would have to really understand
what aspects of bilingualism matter
similarly exe executive control is not
this one thing um there as I mentioned
before lots of different components to
it and um you're likely to see effects
show up in some environments and
circumstances and not in others
depending on who you are interacting
with uh what languages you are using
it's almost a little bit like exercise
um we generally assume and and know and
there is so much convincing evidence
that exercise is beneficial exercise is
good for you but that doesn't mean that
all kinds of exercise are good for all
types of uh let's say health outcomes we
would really want
to understand what kind of exercise
benefits what kind of uh Health measures
so in the same way uh language
experience is in a way exercise for your
brain and so understanding what aspects
of that exercise benefit what type of
cognitive processes is a more accurate
way of um asking those questions and
they don't just apply to Executive
function they apply to behavioral
research in
general uh people differ we are not all
the
same um so we've talked about infancy
childhood adulthood um I'll give you one
example uh of consequences of
bilingualism and multilingualism later
in life and that's
um dementia Alzheimer's and other types
of dementia and there is
evidence that knowing two or more
languages delays the onset of
Alzheimer's and other types of Dementia
by four to six years depending on the
study um and there are now also
so National level studies that
um show that countries that have two or
more official languages have lower
incidents of dementia of Alzheimer's at
the national level uh with actually a
direct correlation between the number of
languages spoken in the country and um
the incidents of dementia so the more
languages uh spoken officially in the
country the um lower the incidence of
dementia so it seems that the effects of
bilingualism and multilingualism are
really pervasive for the individual and
for societies um at large so I'll stop
there but of course anyone who is
interested um can dig in deeper into the
research there are so many research
articles published in scientific
journals all over the world there are
Laboratories um doing research on
bilingualism multilingualism on every
single continent in almost every country
so um there is a lot more to be to be
said on this topic yeah for sure that
was a fascinating coverage and I think
uh one point I want to sort of follow up
with is on this channel I think
obviously my background being in biology
and sort of Aging research I'm
fascinated by ways in which we can
prevent things like denture and so
naturally findings like that is super
striking and so to what extent can we
actually explain why things like being
bilingual multilingual might be able to
prevent
denture yeah that's a good question this
research is still in its um infancy it
was pioneered by Ellen BTO um in Canada
who was the first to find out and to
discover that individuals who are
bilinguals and bilingual multilingual
are diagnosed with Alzheimer's and
Dementia later than
monolinguals
um
and the interesting thing there is not
that bilingual multilinguals don't
develop dementia that their brains don't
deteriorate they do uh what happens is
that they compensate functionally for
the anatomical deterioration so if you
look at a bilingual brain and
monolingual brain with a same level of
impact of deterioration the bilingual
brain is able to function at a higher
level cognitively than the monolingual
brain and then um the flip side of that
is of course that individual ual who
function cognitively at the same level
their brains are actually in different
uh States so what happens there it seems
that uh bilinguals are compensating by
using the connections that have been
built over time in their other language
or languages and one way to explain that
is imagine if you always take the same
Bridge or the same rooad home uh over
years and you know you go to work you
come back you always take the same road
and then one day you come home and on
the way home you see that that road has
collapsed um if there are no other ways
to reach home if that's the only Road
you know or that that exists then you
are in trouble you can never reach home
again in way but if there are other
roads and other Bridges uh that have
been built over time and you know um of
those roads and bridges you just reroute
and take another route and you still
reach your destination in the same way
the connections that have been built um
at the neural level between your
language and your experiences your
memories your
um uh your sort of
life experiences over the years now have
um other connections that have been
built that can potentially align you to
compensate uh for the anatomical
deterioration that you may be
experiencing so um it's one of those use
it or lose it and a richness of neural
connection explanations that seem to be
accounting for that um but we are only
at the beginning of this field um and
and research in this area is still very
much uh happening and as as new tools
are being um developed new statistical
analysis to tools new brain Imaging
tools uh we are gaining a better
understanding of what exactly learning
and using multiple languages does for
brain health no I think it's definitely
worth pursuing it further and I mean I
guess maybe we don't have the answer at
the moment but obviously is it true that
different languages are they differ in
their complexity and maybe there are
certain languages that would have even
more benefits than others or do you
think it's more based on like the number
of languages one might be able to
speak um I don't know that we um can say
that one language is better than another
it's it comes down to the type of
language experience sometimes um when
you learn languages that are more
different it allows you to learn more
new information so that can be
beneficial other times when you learn
languages that are more similar you get
a bigger workout because it's harder to
control competitions between languages
that are more similar so if you are for
example an English speaker who's learned
let's say Spanish and it's learned in
Spanish and then attempts to learn let's
say Italian or French or Portuguese or
Romanian or any other romance language
you can often find that you know Spanish
tends to pop up when you're trying to
new to use your new romance language and
it takes more effort to control more
similar languages so
um it really depends on the type of the
experiences a fluency as well how we
learn our different languages but now
one language as of now we cannot say
that one language is better than another
I see yeah that makes sense and so it
seems like one benefit of being
bilingual or multilingual is maybe
preventing dementia but is it through
that another potential benefits is being
more creative in the thought
process that's a that's um a also a very
good question you you you uh hit on all
the really important interesting points
and I'm glad um there is some evidence
increasingly so that being uh bilingual
multilingual boosts creativity and we
are now conducting research in the lab
precisely to look at this question this
is a relatively new area for us but we
are finding that people who speak two or
more languages see um items that not
that are not related as more related
than monolinguals that they can make
connections between things that people
who don't speak multiple languages can't
um the way we're currently explaining
that um there are a couple of
explanation one is
that each concept has multiple feature
features that contributes to it so for
example if you think of what is a bike
in English um you may think of things
like wheels and handlebars and exercise
and gym um if you think of a bike in
Dutch you will have some features that
are shared with English like um wheels
and handlebar but perhaps instead of gym
you are more likely to think
Transportation um or you're more likely
to think about you know having um a
basket on it and traffic and then if you
speak French you may have uh still some
things that overlap with both English
and Dutch like wheels and handlebar but
then other components that only overlap
with one Ling which may be BAS get and
then unique components again like a
baguette which is a French stereotype
but for the ease of ease of conversation
here we'll use that so A person who
speaks multiple languages their mental
representation of bike differs and now
you have all this connections um where
you know you may have a connection
between uh baguette and um exercise or
or basket or whatever that is stronger
because of the coactivation that this
Concepts experience in their bilingual
multilingual mind so you you your
your representations of this
Concepts um is different than if you
don't speak those languages so um
another example is that in some
languages the same word can translate
onto two different words in another
language um and then when you are a
speaker of those languages and those two
concepts that share translation are
repres presented closer in your mind so
you are able to see connections between
things and this is this the a level of
meaning but you also have more
similarities at the level of form so
um if two words share form they are more
likely to
um to be represented as more similarly
in one's mind and we often experience
that where the wrong word pops up
because it sounds so similar similar to
another word speakers of multiple
languages experien that often where if
they hear a word in one language and
it's um it's sounds very similar as a
word in another language it makes them
think of that word and it reminds them
of associated concept um so this
experience is so um frequent we've
actually done quite a few studies using
eye tracking recording people's eye
movements um that show that people who
speak multiple languages when they hear
one word they make movements to objects
that have a name that sounds similar in
those other languages so I'll give you
an example if you're an English speaker
and you hear the word marker and if I
tell you to pick up a marker and I
record your eye movements if there are
marbles on the table you make eye
movements to the marbles because marker
and marbles sound similar you're not
aware of them they happen in a fractions
of you know a millisecond this very
quick stic eye movements but there it is
it shows that both are coactivated in
parallel now if you speak Spanish and
you hear a marker if you're Spanish
bilingual and there is a butterfly uh
flying around and the Spanish word for
butterfly is Mariposa and you hear
marker you're likely to make IM
movements to the Mariposa because you
share they the two words share word
onset if you speak Russian and there is
a stamp on the table on the desk and the
Russian word for
um uh stamp is Mara you're going to make
eye movements to the stamp so you have
this closer relationship between words
and I just now
inadvertently produced one of those
examples where I used the word table
instead of desk because in the native
languages that I know there is only one
word for desk and table and it's Masa so
um the two words desk and table are
represented much closer in my mind than
in the mind of an English speaker so um
creativity one of the components of
creativity is seeing connections and
making connections and connecting things
that other people don't see as connected
um which is what we think is one of the
contributing mechanisms that explains
why children and adults who speak too
languages often score uh higher on U
many creativity tasks oh and interesting
you've definitely made me uh want to
keep sticking with this Japanese
learning for sure and speaking of like
just learning a language obviously you
you can speak multiple languages um what
evidence or like to what extent uh or
what are the best ways to actually go
about learning a language I know that
there are various different methods that
are reported and also claims that you
know once you learn one language it's
very easy to learn uh other languages so
from your experience and what you've
read is what to what extent is this
true yeah it is true with so bilinguals
are um better at learning a third
language than monolinguals at learning a
second language and it seems like with
each language you learn it becomes
easier and easier to learn new languages
and people used to think and and and say
well some people are just better at
learning languages that's why they
become bilingual in the first place
that's why they become trilingual and
multilingual in the first place and
that's certainly true there is some comp
component of that um there is this
theory of multiple intelligences where
people vary um in how good they may be
at learning a new language or math or
music and that sport so that that's a
contributing variable but it doesn't
tell the whole story it doesn't explain
for example why everyone in the Quebec
area of Canada is a fluent Spanish
English bilingual not everyone but why
there are more fluent B more bilinguals
in Quebec than there are in you know the
northeastern part of the United States
so uh Quebec is a bilingual Province by
law so children have to study both
languages in school
um so it doesn't explain this
geographical uh
bilingualism it seems that with each new
language you learn there is less new
information to learn in yet another
language and the way I can explain this
is basically if you think of aent
diagram the first time you learn a
language you learn this entire circle
with all new information sounds rules um
grammar uh mapping form to meaning all
of that then when you've already gotten
that down and you learn a second
language you already have a lot of that
information and you still learn some new
information in this other Circle but
it's not an entirely New Circle some of
that will overlap then when you learn a
third language some of the new
information you learn um in the third
language overlap with the native with
the first language some with the second
some with both and only um a little bit
more information is completely new so
with each new language um there is less
new information in the way that you
learn so that's part of the explanation
another part of the explanation is that
you do get better at learning you've
already gone through this before you are
better at controlling competition from
your native language language already
your system is a tuned to knowing what
to pay attention to so uh you know it's
like a virtuous cycle where learning
begs more learning the more you learn
the easier it becomes to learn and the
faster you can advance in learning
another language and potentially Beyond
language and learning in
general um as for your other question
what's the best way to learn another
language the real answer to that is that
the best way to learn another language
is to find the approach that works the
best for you and I know it seems like a
um it's not the answer that we're
looking for but it's the same kind of
answer as uh one would give if you being
asked what's the best way to exercise or
what's the best way to invest um there
are some general principles that apply
but in the end what will work is if
adopting a system that you'll be able to
stick with longterm that will allow you
to be um systematic committed regular um
and not just sort of like a flesh and a
pan kind of thing if you find an
approach that works for you that you
enjoy that you can incorporate in your
life then you're more likely to stick
with it and to use it and uh to become
fluent so uh people vary in approaches
they use so some people would use
different languages on different days of
the week so uh even households you know
if if they're a bilingual parents maybe
they use the father's language on Monday
the mother's language on Tuesday the
broad Society language on Wednesday a
foreign language they want to learn on
Thursday this is if you're being very
ambitious um but there are lots of
different ways to do it another way
could be to um use the one parent one
language approach which people often use
so mom always speaks one language dad
always speaks another language or
another approach might be to use the
Heritage language in the home only the
language of the Heritage language of the
family and then the language that's the
dominant language in the society outside
the home um when you raising children
when you are trying to learn another
languages and an adult well right now
apps are very popular and they actually
work quite well because they capitalize
on what we know about um the reward
circuit in the brain and they built in a
form of um
a game all almost so you get this little
reward every time you do something right
and um it allows you to advance levels
so um it seems to work and a lot of
people are finding those ways very
effective uh immersion is a very
effective way to learn another language
either by uh travel or studying in
another country developing relationships
with people who speak multiple languages
is also um a wonderful way to improve
your social interactions which are so
important for mental health uh physical
health lots of different things so just
trading language lessons so if you're
learning Japanese if you find a Japanese
speaker who wants to learn English and
you um interact with them even online of
course in person is great but um right
now the internet makes it possible to
interact with people all over the world
and sort of trading that you can
independently learn on your own but then
Comm communicating with each other um is
an excellent way to learn another
language um my brother was trading
Swedish and English lessons um more than
10 years ago with um another
student and
um the outcome of those lessons being
trade traded is that the Swedish person
with whom he traded language lessons has
now been my sister-in-law for more than
10 years so you never know where those
uh lessons um can lead uh but really you
know whatever whatever you enjoy finding
what makes so I used to have a PhD
student in the lab who always had all
his devices set to French all the
interfaces all the um settings whenever
he used a computer phone TV it was all
in French to help him uh you know keep
up with his Fringe or um watching movies
listening to music without subtitles
really whatever makes you happy whatever
works for you if this is a source of joy
and pleasure and not you know yet
another thing that you have to do then
you are much more likely to become
successful and um and even if you won't
be fluent it will improve your quality
of life because you'll do something you
enjoy and that makes you happy yeah I
can well first I can I can vou for the
apps so I'm a to lingo and I definitely
don't want to break my streak at the
moment um but also you're right with the
imersion and just communicating with
people who speak that language so the
reason I chose Japan was I was in uh
Japanese even was I was in Japan the
summer so I did got to try and have some
impass and communication and I think
yeah from my side it was I always love
to learn from people and obviously I can
speak English but if I can speak their
language as well then I can understand
their way of life and understand how
they see things and their explanations
and as you said the sort of social
benefits for mental health and I think
that someone somewhat leads on to like
uh psycholinguistics or at least I think
maybe maybe I'm wrong but I believe
that's more your interest the cognitive
psychology associated with languages and
I think although we've spoken about some
Concepts already um what are some of the
major findings in this field um that
you've been associated
with yeah
so we are really doing a nice job
covering touching on multiple topics in
the book of course um and then the book
goes into all of this into much more
depth but yes so I'm really interested
in the psychology of language and how
the language we use shapes the way we
think how um language and mind mutually
influence each other how they interact
um there is the famous superar Warf
hypothesis does language shape thought
is our thought limited by the words we
have to refer to things can we think
about something if we don't have labels
and language and words for it these are
some of the broader philosophical
questions that we're interested in uh
what comes first thought or language um
is another one and how do we know
because most of the time we study
thought through language we need to have
words to even label our
findings uh many of the discoveries that
have been made
in in multiple fields of science um
become
possible um or uh facilitated by having
the Lang the language to use to refer to
those Concepts so many words did not
exist just um you know a few decades or
of course centuries ago we are
constantly uh discovering new knowledge
and and having words and labels putting
labels in place
so our language in the way our words can
be a bit of a it can function as a prism
through which we see reality and the
world around us and the reality that you
see and that I see and that you know
your listeners see um are shaped by our
languages there is a lot of research on
that and it's not I don't want to take
to take a fully deterministic approach I
know that many do where they just say
you know language determin thought if
you don't have a word you can't have
that concept but it does shape the way
they we think it does influence um our
thoughts and this has been studied in
many domains the most famous one is
color for example where people who have
multiple words for color uh think of
color differently remember color
differently um for example there is
research with Greek and Russian speakers
um where there are two different labels
for light and blue uh light blue and
dark blue okay and speakers of those
languages who have two labels for light
blue and dark blue um make decisions
about different shades of blue much
faster or remember um images of
different shades of blue much faster
than people that only have one um shade
of blue in one label for different
shades of for all shades of blue in
their language um with color the way to
illustrate that is to to use rainbow the
rainbow is an example because most of
the time when we think about the rainbow
we think of the colors of the rainbow
through the prism of our language and if
our language has six seven eight however
many colors uh we grew up thinking of
the rainbow having and you know as kids
we drew a lab uh the the rainbow with
the colors that we knew the rainbow has
then that's what we think a rainbow is
but in reality the rainbow has an
infinite number of colors each color
changing into another by just one pixel
there is just you know the the full
color spectrum is represented in the
rainbow so um this is one illustration
of how our labels and our languages
influence our perception and how we see
and how we think about color but color
is not the only way not the only example
language influences how we think about
time how we think about Mass how we
think about um emotions how we think
about relationships uh there are
languages that have different words for
different types of relationships
different types of Love different uh
emotions um and that changes how we
think who we are how we interact with
the world I know this is like we are
nearing the end of the conversation when
we Broach this topic but there are this
is like an entire other field with
classes being taught books being written
on this topic on how language shapes
thought um and how the two interact how
how thought shapes language as well the
two definitely go hand in hand um it
seems like and there are so many other
areas of research within the psychology
of language field right now we're doing
some work on sound symbolism so is the
form completely arbitrary from me
disconnected from meaning or are there
some uh consistent patterns between the
form of words and language and the
meaning they carry this is another
highly contested area of research and um
I'm happy to go into as much or as
little of it as you'd like but I'll let
you uh direct the conversation in
whatever uh Direction you'd like it to
go oh no I mean for i' be interested to
hear in more detail about some of these
studies um because I think um from well
from my side I really do think I'm
interested in this topic partly because
as a scientist we write in English our
journals I mean not say I'm English
anyway so that's that's great but we're
trying to describe our findings they
feel like if we don't have the
vocabulary to actually be able to do
that then are we somehow you know
limiting the progress that we can make
in the field and so yeah I'd be
definitely interested to hear more of
your
studies yeah that's a really good
insight and it's a whole other New
Direction that that you've mentioned
just now how the fact that most
scientific research is being published
in English is being conducted on English
speakers and not just English speakers
but a relatively small portion of the
populations what a uh what I would what
I will refer to as weird population
Western educated industrial
industrialized rich and democratic
nations so the majority of of research
and researchers come from uh weird
Nations um but this is only a small the
minority of the world's population and
what happens as a result is we are
leaving this huge segment of Humanity
out of research which gives us an
incomplete and
inaccurate understanding of humanity
mind brain potential all of that if
we're only looking at certain kind of
speakers we don't get a full um
understanding of what we are capable of
as as humans one of the parallels uh I
make when I talk about this is um to the
field of Medicine where historically
most research for example on heart
disease and diabetes was done on white
men but now we know that heart disease
manifests differently in women and
diabetes manifests differently in
populations indigenous to North and
South America so if we don't include
women or if we don't include populations
indigenous to North and South America in
research then we don't get a full
understanding of diabetes or heart
disease or you know mechanisms uh
driving those uh uh conditions and ways
to treat them um and really don't have a
full understanding of those medical
phenomena in the same way if we just
look at monolinguals if we just look at
English speakers or um uh weird
populations we don't have a full
understanding of how language Works how
the mind works um
and in scientific research it leaves out
this uh potential
that imagine how much further science
could be if we included and then if it
was um not limiting to just a very small
portion of of population yeah no exactly
there's a something that from reading
your book really made me think about
especially it's as well see I do a lot
of science communication it's something
I always think about you know all my
videos I make in English and so I mean I
also realized as well there are ways now
of using translators online to convert
one my English written uh research paper
into a different language but there's
always like you can't go one to one
directly necessarily between
languages um so yeah so I think well
then what is the solution the solution
is to publish the same paper in multiple
languages or do you think there's a
solution that there should be another
language or I think well on from that is
there should there be one universal
language or you know realize it's
important to keep separate
languages well it's
it's not an easy question to answer I
think broadening first of all learning
multiple languages is a good place to
start so um if you can read research
papers in other languages already then
that helps
um so acknowledging this multilingual
population learning multiple languages
is one thing now ai is making it
possible to easily quickly translate uh
scientific papers and scientific
findings in other languages
um some Publications are now working uh
towards allowing publication of research
in multiple
languages or having um editors who can
help speakers of by the languages um
edit their papers in a way that meet
their the standards and the requirements
uh of a journal that publishes in a
specific language for example um science
is definitely becoming more inclusive
now than it used to
be
um I don't know that I have the full
answer to it I
think linguistic diversity is the the
the it's the new the new kid on the on
the Block in that way really
understanding that there is so much
knowledge
that
um making it accessible to
everyone would benefit the advancement
of science and
technology so for example when uh the
Chinese um scientist who discovered a
developed I believe the treatment for
malaria when she received the Nobel
Prize at that point only one of her
papers I think was translated into
English um so the majority of English
speakers didn't have access to that
research and to this day there is a lot
of wonderful research published in other
countries that um that the popula The
Wider population doesn't have access to
so we are just becoming aware of that
and and there is more online interaction
and not just online interaction between
um countries and people the world is
increasingly becoming a smaller place so
we'll see what happens in the next few
Generations I think that the evolution
of science the evolution of knowledge
and the evolution of humanity in the
next uh few years and decades will
happen at at a speed that um exceeds
those of the previous generations
because of the advancement of AI yeah no
I really hope so and well given that you
mentioned AI I know like a lot of the
newer like chat GPT models that're
they're built on large language models I
guess the keyw that being language
and so um yeah I mean to what extent is
there overlap between what these AI
systems are doing and what we know as
languages that's
another uh huge topic that you're
approaching I know that when we bring
this up we think oh it's just you know
two- minute conversation but there is so
much to be said there um so AI right now
relies on this large language models
and
um it is advancing much faster than most
people who study language thought they
would
um it seems that simply learning the
probabilities of statistical
probabilities of something cooccurring
together um has enabled language models
to uh learn and Advance very quickly if
of course they still don't have
intentionality they don't have pragmatic
skills yet they non-organic yet
um but there are a lot of similarities
and a lot of differences between natural
languages and uh artificial
languages um
I I talk about this a little bit in the
book and I've been thinking about this
uh sense as well um what are the
consequences of artificial IAL um
intelligence for natural languages that
that humans speak I think initially we
think that it will be a benefit and a
wonderful thing to have a I we you and I
have just talked a few minutes ago about
the fact that AI can translate on the
Fly text can translate speech detect
just the other day you know I was
speaking into my um app and it'll on the
flight translate into the other link
detect the language and translate into
the other language that I wanted it
translated to um it can help record and
preserve dying languages so we would
think oh what a great uh thing can
benefit for natural languages but if we
take a longer term view beyond the um uh
seemingly immediate
benefits I think that AI
will not be a good thing for that for
the diversity of human languages and
what I mean by that is um there are over
7,000 languages spoken in the world
today um few and fewer every year
because uh speakers of languages are
dying disappearing um every every few
months every year
and AI I think will accelerate the
demise of some of those languages and
what I mean by that is only a few
languages will really run to the top
those um that have the largest online
footprint and the largest online
databases from which this AI models can
learn um because the more information
the more uh the larger the base on which
an AI Model A large language model can
learn the better that model will become
so there is only a handful there only a
few languages and it depends you know
who you talk to let's say 20 um that
have truly really expansive online uh
presence and so let's say 20 200 let's
say however many languages you want to
to choose but it's not going to be seven
plus thousand um that will have equally
large
uh uh and Powerful models and eventually
the stronger the more powerful uh models
like an invasive species really will
drive out the um models that are built
on smaller languages that have a smaller
online footprint and a smaller database
on which those languages are trained
because then those languages won't be as
powerful so um I think within a few
Generations we if if it things contining
the way they do um we will
lose this diversity of languages and if
it is true that language and thought are
tightly connected and that language
shapes the way we think then this will
also impact the diversity of thought as
many languages um disappear the cultural
background the way of thinking in ways
that those languages shape will
disappear as well um and you know it's
almost like a science fiction film where
you have increased diversity of human
thought just or decrease sorry decreased
diversity of human thought coincide or
or develop just as this AI models become
more and more powerful so it doesn't bod
well to have this increasingly strong
powerful wonderful artificial
intelligence models and then
disappearing languages disappearing
diversity of thought for humans um but I
don't want to be the the Doomsday
scenario I think nobody really knows and
nobody can predict what will happen
everyone is making uh predictions based
on their knowledge background and um we
shall see I think Europe the European
Union has just recently um developed
some guidelines for how to uh proceed uh
with regard to AI I think other
countries will as well but controlling
and
developing it's not something that can
be easily um
controlled with laws and rules
because
um you you can have individuals or
nations that will not follow those rules
so um it's it's
uh one of the current applied
consequences of the psychology of
language that we are all interested in
or that I'm interested in yeah no I
think you're uh well I think it's
definitely right that there are going to
be both benefits and consequences that
we should be thinking about now because
we just don't have we don't know right
it's hard to predict um the one I guess
potential bright side I can give for my
side is I have obviously dabbled a
little bit with using these uh chat gbt
models and I did as one of my prompts uh
ask it if we could create a language
together um and it was trying to help me
come up with our own language but
obviously I realize that's just a bit of
fun and it's hard to I don't think it's
going to be the way to donate
necessarily novel languages but it is I
guess some insight that maybe we can use
these large language models to become
more creative ourselves and to bounce
ideas that
way oh that sounds like fun and sounds
like something that I would love to do
too maybe there is a bit of a psych
psycholinguist in you as well um yeah
it's um it will be interesting to see
what happens yeah for sure and I think
it only reinforces how important the
work that you're doing is um to
understand uh like the benefits of
languages the benefits of learning
languages and how it yeah changes the
way that we communicate with people and
perceive the world around us so I can
only highly recommend my viewers to read
your books I know we've only sort of
jumped around and skimmed through many
of the topics and yeah it's just been
amazing to be able to speak with you
today thank you I I appreciate you
saying that um interest inter inly there
are actually two English translations of
the book which we were just talking
about you know different ways of
thinking there is a US English version
and then the U UK English version yeah
so um so whichever language uh people
choose I hope they enjoy it I hope they
learn a lot and um I refer to it as my
love letter to the bilingual and
multilingual mind but really um it's not
just for bilinguals and multilinguals I
think people who are bilingual and
multilingual will get the most out of it
because there just there is so little uh
there in the Popular Science literature
written about bilinguals and
multilinguals that um it really just
helps get in an insight into
bilingualism and multilingualism but uh
it does go beyond natural languages so I
hope I hope people enjoy it learn a lot
from it and uh it helps them think about
language and mind but thank you yeah
know I think it definitely will and also
for monolinguals it definitely
encourages you to to learn another
language so um yeah no thank you again
for doing this with me today it was such
a pleasure to talk with you good luck
with your dissertation defense on Friday
three days you'll be a doctor in three
days so that's exciting um I've enjoyed
listening to uh many of your videos so
and watching many of your videos so
thank you for the work you do bringing
science
to the wider readership and and taking
it out from journals and labs to
everyone oh thank you so
much